i'm glad i'm here it's friday we're
doing another episode of logo redesign
and
in case you're new to the format it's
logos you love
or maybe i should say logos you love to
hate and we're going to be
redesigning today with a new new
participant new designer his name is
maxwell billings
and in case you're unfamiliar with his
work go out and check out
madeby87.com madeby87.com
and you can check out his work also on
instagram at madebuy87
and this is some of his work it's super
impressive
and i like seeing this and and this is
probably
a little departure for us because
usually we talk to people who are really
concentrated on logo design but
here in maxwell's work we see lots of
things like
copywriting signage menu design
exhibit design there's a lot of stuff
that's going on packaging and i like
seeing this because i think this is
where
many designers if you're if you have the
skill if you have the aptitude for this
is where you should be
you should be thinking about the
entirety of the brand from
every point of consumer interaction so
i'm really excited to see what maxwell
comes up with
now he's chosen to take on united
airlines
now i was unfamiliar with this but
apparently united airlines had
redesigned their logo with their
acquisition of another airline
and so this is the the weird combo mark
that they've come up with
because if you had to redesign the
original saw bass logo i might have some
some issues with that but here we are
and so we want to see how he went from
this
to this and i have to ask you first of
all maxwell why
why did you pick united airlines of all
logos to redesign
sure uh well uh thankfully i have a
couple reasons and
that's the first portion of my
presentation here
so really the first reason that
i have for why united is there's a lot
of nostalgia
there so it's a it's a chicago company
i'm
from chicago you know flying out of
o'hare airport which is the united hub
was always the the thing when you were a
kid
the last dance was just on espn
everyone's watching
the bulls again and of course the bulls
play at the united center the
house that jordan built and there's just
a lot of that
uh you know that that sort of heritage
to travel and and growing
up uh the second part as you mentioned
is design legacy so you have
the original or one of the original
redesigns of the logo back in 1974
by saul bass and then in 1997
you have the update to the logo from
michael beirut and pentagram this is the
uh
infamous tulip logo design that
everybody loves and
you know one of the big things when ever
you dive into
learning about a brand is doing a little
more homework and
in the case of michael beirut i actually
flipped open his book and completely
forgot that there's an entire section
about united airlines in there so to all
the
all the students who are uh you know
wondering about
you know how do you research and learn
more and buy some books
they're they're good things to have
around uh but
you know teeing up the this presentation
of the the why
united uh you know even in the last
paragraph of his book
uh on the on the opening page it even
quite you know honestly says uh it was
not dustin the last united merged with
arrival and in a series of trade-offs
motivated motivated less by marketing
theory
than by the logic of the deal memo they
married their name to their new partner
symbol
a new era began without us it had been
an amazing ride
so kind of that admission that united
was walking away from this
heritage of design legacy that they had
uh the third reason is as you mentioned
it is a bit of a horse by design uh the
cur or the uh the prior mark uh did feel
a little bit
uh you know sort of um it felt
uh there was some heritage there it felt
strong and then of course
when the merger occurred with
continental airlines
it felt a little uh horse by committee
when both of those were merged together
to come into the one
new logo of taking continental's blue
their look and merging it just with the
united name
i feel it felt very bored room designed
i'll i'll put it that way
uh and then finally the the general
moment we're in
i know a lot of people are staying home
i know like myself
love to travel and there's kind of that
hunger to get back out there and safely
travel again
and you know if you're going to work on
a project might as well be
something fun uh you know with the um
you know with the loss of uh virgin
airlines
um oh oh god hang on
my uh my zoom just uh restarted on me
okay we get still here okay perfect uh
so uh with the with the loss of virgin
airlines
um in the united states it's a real
bummer that
um oh no problem something happened
okay now we're back
yeah it looks like yeah we're back
something is happening
we all went through a zoom update at the
exact same time
we're back i could see the zoom jonah
can you see us
all right jonah's got to do something
hold on hang tight yeah
oh you keep talking okay go ahead yeah
no problem uh
with uh with virgin america sort of gone
and acquired by alaskan airlines there
really isn't
a experience airline anymore there it's
it's a lot of um
fighting on low price so it felt like
this is a good opportunity to rethink
who delta
is differentiate on or sorry rethink who
united is
differentiate a little more than i'm
priced uh i
i pulled a quote in here from uh from an
article i read when i was doing my
homework
the delta ceo essentially said that
business travel won't come back
ever to pre-pandemic levels the idea of
that luxury travel
first business class is probably going
away so
how can we take some of that sort of
care and thinking and bring it into the
overarching airline experience
obviously you know for something as
simple as logo design this is definitely
overthinking it but this is sort of in
my opinion
the necessary things you need to go
through to gain that perspective
so wait wait wait before you continue
yeah just jump sure because
yeah i want to hear the rest of what you
have to say but i was just thinking
that that is sad if that's true because
when we can travel when we have traveled
in the past
i really like traveling because it's
like my bridge to a whole nother world a
whole nother culture
and maybe they're starting to disappear
this kind of
luxury travels thing but it would be sad
if that were the case
and one airline that i just want to give
a shout out to is jetblue and they have
mint
and mint doesn't cost a ton more but
they they do a really good job
of putting you that business class seat
and it's like something that you can lay
down in and the quilted blankets and i
was like this is really nice and
i feel like it's worth whatever money i
can pay for it so i hope this is not the
case
yeah right it's uh i i mean me too i
i you know as you just sort of stated
you're willing to pay a little bit more
for the the sort of comfort of travel
and not just feel like a
packed bus soaring through the sky
all right so a little bit of brand
homework
as we mentioned you know this is the
mark
they went through their entire uh a
recent redesign process where they
rolled out
the kind of frankenstein of the
continental look and the united look
into this very blue playing up the globe
um it feels very corporate uh sort of
expected there's really
not a lot here from a design
visual perspective where it cues into
something really of strong
interest right there's nothing terribly
engaging with it
but during my initial research i started
to pull
and uh dive into a couple different
interesting things that that cued up my
thinking for the logo
uh the first was the sub brand that
united has
called polaris which is their business
and first class
uh sort of sub category of higher luxury
higher touch more into the hospitality
world
and looking into it they use
this star imagery in a in a very uh
subtle way that i thought was
interesting it cued into some more
uh emotional feelings and
you could tell a bit more of a story
there than just sort of
you know the the globe treatment they
had so i kind of put this on my wall as
something to potentially
take a look at and come back to here's
just some examples of how that all
looks from the polaris perspective
you're kind of as
as you'd expect your first class type
experience
the next thing i looked at in addition
to where
visually could the logo go from a shape
and design perspective but also to from
a color standpoint
so i took a look at all the different
airlines that
exist out there the top domestic and the
top
international and tried to figure out is
there a gap somewhere
in color design that we can exploit
and as i sort of sorted things out kind
of discovered it very quickly
you have your spikes in the reds and you
have your spikes in the blues
but there were two areas that stuck out
as
opportunity the sort of blue
green aqua area and then the purple
indigo
all the way to the right now one of the
nice things
is that with the united palette the way
that they have it currently set up
they obviously favor the dark blues and
leaning into that very corporate blue
world which
you know can be a tough thing to own
generally
but given the observation that i made
just before about the greens and purples
we could simply flip the hierarchy
around
still use the united brand colors but
just do a little bit of a tweak as far
as
what's primary and secondary
so on to the thinking uh
so buffle design requires strategy
obviously
as you're saying so start with why this
is just sort of a
immediate brain dump of you know in my
journal
i for as much as i love my ipads and
computers and iphones and i'm the total
apple guy
sometimes just a pencil and a moleskin
notebook is the way to go
just for getting ideas out there so i
just started going into
writing down all the things that i think
about
travel what does it mean to me what is
the actual
sort of magic behind it because it is an
emotional thing you're going to
another place you are meeting other
people you're
you know gathering an experience that
you wouldn't have otherwise so
you know how does united fit into that
the larger
elements that i pulled out were to
aspire to a higher purpose
connect people with their destination uh
not just say oh you know we're we're
here to fight people meeting people it's
like
no you're you're kind of a temporary
hotel that people stay in
while they get to that cool place that
they want to go
no one's really excited to hop on an
airplane these days
uh we want to make travel feel special
again and then
provide design as an experience not
necessarily a just promotional tool
so one of the quotes that i like to pull
out and you know i like to pull
inspiration from everywhere is this
great anthony bourdain quote that travel
is about that gorgeous feeling
of teetering into the unknown and that
sounds fresh so
anthony bourdain right there yeah right
voice over as he's just walking down
some you know street somewhere
um so based on that that idea of the
unknown i started to
think about all right what is the
ultimate unknown right we think about
space we think about the infinite vast
of
just being able to look up and see the
stars and it's a
very human thing that everyone has done
uh you know going all the way back
through all of humanity that idea of
looking up at the stars and being
something a bit more aspirational and
then
on top of it polaris is the name of the
north star
so just started looking at photography
and trying to get a feel for
how this could all come together and
then you know going back to
the color exploration of all right we
have
greens and we have purples and blues
all those can work together naturally in
a way when you look at something like
the northern lights
all those colors can weave in and out of
each other and
like bob ross says we don't make
mistakes we make happy accidents
so this is kind of a happy accident that
just sort of
i i was as i was going through the
process of discovering and thinking of
trying to create all right how do i want
this start
to to begin to look not only in the
sense of the logo but how do we then
expand it
to all the different touch points of the
brand
because a logo doesn't live on its own
it's never just
isolated in a field of white space it
lives somewhere
so hopped in back to the good old
notebook and just started doodling
in portfolio school our teachers always
said start with a hundred
and then throw them out and then do
another hundred
and then you'll start to get somewhere
so lots of little doodles
of the u the shape um
just playing with the letter form very
simply quick little sketches
to inform the design process
so here uh playing around with uh you
know
overlapping geometry getting back a
little bit to that saw bass
tulip u logo that is you know sort of
heralded as one of the best logo designs
of all time by
one of the best logo designers of all
time going through and
and you know in sort of my drawing like
on the bottom
left all of a sudden i thought all right
what about like a star
whooshing uh you know what if it just
sort of left a trail like a comet do we
go into this world of celestial
a bit more um you know
playing around and redrawing the actual
tulip logo to learn a little bit more
about
how is the motion if it were you know
extrapolated into a 3d space how would
that end up looking
and then of course stepping away from it
completely and then just going to other
stuff and
you know continuously drawing and
doodling keeping all those
mental ideas you know keeping those
plates spinning
so to speak
so here uh kept going kept taking the uh
the initial ideas that i had you know
playing up that idea of the u
of the star motion sort of swooping
through
playing around with uh you know do we
flatten it out at the the base of the u
do we try to build in some type of uh
you know representation of motion to to
you know give that star more of a sense
of
speed and velocity uh going even
further into all right if we took that
same
motion idea and tried to build into a
typeface how would that look
uh just some initial ideas who knows
maybe we'll come back to it treating the
you as a shield again just playing
around with a lot of different ideas of
what's working what's not working where
does kind of
my instinct take me uh as far as what
feels like a right fit
even you know quite honestly just
writing
right next to stuff to be like it's not
really that good
um going even further you know stepping
away from ideas but then coming back
there's a couple different things
happening here uh that
will go to as far as logos that didn't
necessarily make the cut but
you know using that shadow of the u uh
as i started playing around with it
almost kind of felt like a airplane seat
on the left
and then kind of the window on the right
i thought that was you know something
interesting that was kind of happening
um and then of course always
i kind of found myself gravitating right
back to that idea of
space star and that motion of the u
and then any airline branding wouldn't
be complete without you know
quickly thinking about how does it look
on the side of a plane because that's
probably the biggest printing of the
logo and
of the design that you'll probably
interact with and then
a cool astronaut why not
yeah right all right so we'll hop into
the work
uh as uh as i pointed out before we kind
of have this uh geometric u
that has that shadow uh extrapolated out
has a little bit of a feel of a airline
seat and a window
i thought to myself what if we push that
even further and
all of a sudden it got into this very
sort of 70s retro
bubbly uh type vibe that didn't
necessarily feel like it was a fit
again playing with shapes trying to
evoke a little bit of that
saw bass tulip logo keeping that in the
back of my head
um and then going to
that idea of the star from the polaris
logo and trying to come up with a way to
develop that and draw that and how does
that
integrate in with the u uh you know with
this one you almost kind of get like uh
it almost evokes uh the shape of an
airplane a little bit
you know heading heading you know
downward but
the real uh sort of aha moment i had was
when i took a look at the
u the tulip u and used the uh
the curve of that bottom left corner to
create the
uh the different quadrants of the star
so that was my way of
calling back to that era of tradition to
pull that out of nowhere because or pull
that from somewhere and
uh you know make sure that whenever i
design
things one of the things i always like
to do is build a little bit of a story
and have it so that things are tied to
other references within the brand so in
this example here
pulling that curve from the old logo to
sort of inspire and carry through those
little design elements
just creates little moments of surprise
so now that i did that little
exploration
let's go ahead and make a logo about to
play my
little time lapse uh video here
okay before you before you do that oh
are you playing all right sorry okay
hold on
sorry sorry first of all i just want to
say you're doing an amazing job of
talking us through the entire design
process you're thinking super logical
very clear i love the way that you broke
even the color palette down to
to find space where it wasn't too
crowded identifying there are a lot of
marks that are in the red space and the
blue
but not much in between those two parts
people are commenting on excellent
keynote great presentation so far
i i could tell you're a well-trained
designer and you you must be used to
doing big level presentations because
you're very good at it
so kudos to you it's one of the
strongest keynotes on the logo design
series that we've had thus far so
without further ado go ahead and play
the video
well thank you so much
do you need a drum roll here is that
here he goes not yet here we go
and you're working in illustrator here
working in illustrator
uh just kind of going through and
building out the different elements so
there we just saw pulling the curvature
from
the the tulip u to develop the star
and in this part here referencing back
to that tulip to try to
bring through the uh
the sort of curvature at the bottom
because it's not even
it sort of follows a bit more of a
natural organic
flow uh you know it's not just sort of a
uniform line
all the way through which i thought was
just sort of a interesting
learn from the greats saw bass himself
type of thing
so now we get to
the full logo design oh neat that's
pretty awesome
are you doing this in keynote uh no that
was
a after effects special oh you're
breaking it all out
look at him mark people are commenting
yeah i'm gonna present something
let's present it yes you should do it
yeah people are wondering how you did it
but i saw that you're doing that in
keynote but there's a lot of this
advanced animation it does look like
you're doing something beyond
some more complicated masking it reveals
there yeah
it's a it's a fun program to know uh but
don't let anybody know that you know it
because then they're going to ask you to
do all their logo reveal videos and
editing and stuff like that so
just a pro tip um so now we get to
the composed logo here um
you know breaking down just a couple
quick elements of it
one of the things that i really liked
and sort of fell into was
the using that negative space on the
right uh
to create kind of the the whoosh and
trail
from the star as it takes off upwards
and you know on sort of more
aspirational trajectory up
um as i mentioned before the overlap in
that negative space
down at the base of the u is
following a curve that is a bit more of
a natural
you know doesn't line up and is a
monoform
line weight around the shape just
because
optically sometimes we need to go in
there and make a call
and adjust things so that it looks right
even though it may be mathematically
correct and
mathematically even when you look at it
you'll kind of be like
uh something seems wrong you know that's
why in typography
the you know the vertical strokes and
the horizontal strokes are different
weights
you know just so that optically things
have a bit more of a balance
yeah nice oh sorry go ahead no no nice
nice keep going
thank you uh going into the word mark
here
uh took a uh took a look at the
the old united uh really from the
the redesign and the the update in the
early 90s
uh sorry the mid 90s going all the way
up till the recent redesign helvetica
was
their go-to now don't get me wrong i
love helvetica i use it for
my agency brand font but i think there's
a
stronger bolder more contemporary choice
so
i went with the the workhorse that is
gotham
and going into the
oh there we go uh going in and taking a
look
at the actual word mark made some
custom tweaks so that it isn't just that
standard typeface slapped on there but
let's make some creative choices to give
it a little bit of personality
so the curves that i inserted here
the taking away that sort of top left of
the n
and then adding that shadow under the uh
under the horizontal portion of the t
those are taken directly from the star
in the uh in the larger logo of
the combined word mark so using those
curves and
and bringing those curves through and
other elements of the type
so that when they do sit together they
feel
like a designed element not just a
logo with type right next to it
i just want to say for the record too it
is okay to design a beautiful mark
and just use a typeface just one yes
absolutely right
yeah when possible yeah when possible
try to integrate so that it feels like
this cohesive hole
now you can see that the the the mark
that the maxwell came up with has a
solid shape it has a mono stroke
trail leading to this star form and so
those are like a lot of elements so if
you were to just
quote unquote slap on a typeface it
might feel very foreign so you have to
work
to try to bring these two things so that
they live in the same world
yeah and then on top of that uh you know
making sure that they can
live in the world uh a logo has to work
you know as as simple as black and white
uh
if you noticed with my time lapse videos
you know whenever i design logos i
always start in just a white or black
shape
i never use color until i get to a place
where i say
oh that mark can be identified and
differentiated even when color isn't an
option
so that that's just sort of a an early
logo design
tip that i learned that's helped me a
lot as i've
moved forward in my design career
so then in addition to the uh the mark
that we have here
my you know branding brain started going
a little crazy and i started thinking
all right what are some other cool ways
that
we can up and uh sort of upgrade the the
united
brand and and united feel and
presentation
and like i mentioned whenever i make
design choices if i can
root it in something even if it's super
inside baseball deep i still love doing
it because
when once you find out that little
secret it becomes something fun
so i'll i'll give you a good example so
this is the
uh the opening uh sort of a handful of
notes that lead into
george gershwin's rhapsody in blue which
is the
theme song for united airlines has been
for
you know decades so very iconic
i'm sure everyone's heard it mm-hmm
yes should i play it again we can't hear
it so
i think it's the way our audio set up
you guys know what it is you ought to
like
trust us okay something like that right
yeah exactly not a problem um so
uh basically i i took the song and i put
it into a wave visualizer
and since the the one of the elements
that we're carrying through with the new
brand is this idea of the
sort of aurora borealis i went in
and used that actual the waveform
to create the lines of this aurora
borealis texture that's going to pop
up in a couple places throughout the
brand exploration here
thank you uh you know it's it's it's all
it's all about the little things to
create those moments of surprise and
delight with people
um just like you know the fedex arrow
it's a little conversation piece
uh in addition to that created a custom
halftone texture that utilized that star
shape to give us just another graphical
element to play with
and to integrate into the brand in a way
that felt
uh natural but also felt artistic and
thoughtful
it wasn't just sort of uh you know a
globe texture just to be a globe texture
there's
some room to play with this especially
if you're coming into the brand as an
actual designer
so let's talk about points into detail
there thank you
so for the primary livery of the
of the planes kept the uh the white i
think it's a very clean pretty look
but use the star gradient to create that
natural transition
from white into that aurora
going toward the back of the plane where
it gets dark and
uses you know blues and those blacks
from
the overarching united brand
created a secondary livery that uses a
bit more of the
photography treatment of the northern
lights
can swap those out and create different
plane designs and things like that
there was a point in time when you know
uh airlines would have a bunch of
different colored planes and things like
that and created this sort of
sense of fun of who knows what i'm going
to walk into now
oh and then the the curve going toward
from the middle of the fuselage all the
way back to the tail
again is carrying through that exact
same radius from the
star so the little things of
you know reinforcing your design choices
by actually making design choices you
know based on
the overarching system going to
the rhapsody aurora here we have it
wrapping the entire plane so
you know imagine if you will you're
about to go to the airport hop on a
plane all of a sudden
this pulls up you're like oh party
planes here uh i guess we're
we're going somewhere that is a party
plane right there
i have to say yes there's a pole in the
middle of the plane
yeah and then uh you know i thought a
lot of airlines are having a bit more
fun with the
the underbelly of the plane and going
back to those elements of surprise and
delight
uh thought it would be really fun if you
know there were
cheeky playful actually you know human
one-to-one messages on the bottom of the
planes not just corporate speak but you
know just saying like hey we're out of
here
as you see it as the plane takes off
great way of using underutilized space
that's ignored
i think you could have a lot of fun with
that i could even see them saying
something like uh
if you can read this you're too close
yeah right
they're right you just missed us
[Laughter]
see you sucker yeah so um
even applying the the uh the logo design
further uh you know depending on
application so
for example the the full color logo is
you know on the darker background but
hey if there's an opportunity where
letterpress can be involved why don't we
just use a blind letterpress to create
that
star so that you know it's just a fun
little
design magic that you can sprinkle on
there that can
add just a little bit more surprise and
delight for people
going into the uh seating and sort of
the interior of the plane
um you know using the the logos uh you
know emboss and all the headrests but
going into things like the uh you know
the stitching pattern
on the seats uh pulling that those same
curves and everything from
the portion of rhapsody in blue the
gershwin song
uh that follows those same lines so uh
blew them up a little bit so that they
could
spread out and so they weren't as
compressed but you know the lines on
the seats you could see them as a bit
more like topographical lines
or you know the the fact that they're uh
taking off of the melody from uh the
theme song
taking a look at how it comes to life in
signage actually
you know at an airport where you might
be walking by the lounge
uh you know on a very simple elegant uh
you know purple to green frosted glass
uh type situation
and then how it can come to life in
print so for
business cards for example uh bringing
in
as i mentioned that texture of the the
half tone made from the
star element that is carried throughout
the brand
printed on the backs of the cards here
as this sort of uh
the united take on the evening sky
going into how it comes to life
digitally it does have sort of that
digital contemporary feel to it and i
think that
you know in general even though we're
talking logos i think you know being
thoughtful and saying hey we can add a
little more
human personality to this uh to the the
brand and how we present ourselves
uh you know by saying things like uh you
know once you tap
your destination a little message pops
up it says oh great choice chris
uh so it's it's little things like that
where we can
weave in a bit more personality and be a
bit more thoughtful with
with the brand going into the check-in
process
actually at the airport uh pulling in
that that rhapsody um
borealis in the background becomes the
the new
presentation of the terminal as people
approach
again not a lot of people using blue and
green or sorry uh purple and green but
there's a lot of blues at the airport
this is an
easy way to begin to differentiate and
say oh
follow the purple sign uh you know
follow the green sign
again sort of ways to help them stand
apart
um i'm loving the that you're coming up
with because
you're really designing a system and as
much as we have people talk about doing
branding
they're not really doing branding until
they start to look at the entire
system from top to bottom the way you're
able to visualize
sound and incorporate that the thinking
of the color palette integration
really trying to position them so that
they're differentiated
very thoughtful stuff here really
appreciate what you're doing
i could tell there's a depth of
experience that you've had here you're
not some kid who's just falling off the
design wagon and starting
a lot of comments online and i have to
address them right now which is
sure where you're getting all these
mock-ups from man because i've looked
for airport mock-ups and they're not
easy to find
somebody asked do you own your own plane
or what's the deal here and obviously i
know you're on your own
but i mean the answer is yes but i'm
also a liar
so who knows
yeah i mean the uh a lot of the mock-ups
and everything
are like i use um there's plenty of
websites
like uh uh evato elements um
you pay a monthly fee and get them but
frankly i also just sort of learned how
to retouch in photoshop
so like this image for example was just
an image of the terminal
and i've just through practice have just
gotten good at
how do you lay things into an
environment
and match lighting and shadow so that it
feels like
you know a real thing and not just oh
you very clearly just photoshopped
something in there
right so on this one this is at the
o'hare airport
that you found an image and then you
retouched well here uh
this definitely was so this was the
normal
united terminal uh from o'hare
and went in and retouched it so there's
a lot of little
detail things that i can kind of nerd
out about about when you
i know i can tell you right now i know i
could see it
so you took a united airlines terminal
photograph which was a nice clean
photograph to begin with right
everything looks immaculate
and then you went in and cloned
everything else out and
masked everything so that then you can
begin this whole mock-up process right
yeah yeah i think this is a future
product that you could sell here the
the the maxwell buildings pro airline
mock-up set with airplanes and
seating and all this kind of stuff nice
totally
yeah i'll package it up and i'll i'll
give you a cut
yes call me we can do a deal yeah right
yeah but yeah i mean like for for me but
one of the things that i look at a lot
is you know especially the photos and
mockers and things like that are depth
so a lot of times what you'll see when
people mock something up is
all your design elements look crystal
sharp and
you know really honed in but if you look
at like the the turn styles at the
bottom
you know just apply a blur filter to
match how blurry the environment is and
now all of a sudden it looks like
oh it's a real thing oh it's really
there
chris bartoni bartholomew is saying you
missed the garbage can
chris you're gonna have to get on
yourself it'll be okay is there a
garbage can that you missed i don't even
see that yes
on the right i thought i got it oh i i i
someone has a good eye eagle eye over
there well done bartolone
good one okay but this one you you also
then comped out then you cut everything
out and
mocked it in wow well done so
even uh you know the the screens in the
background the tv screens i i updated
all of those and you know just a
quick messaging note had a little fun
with it so that thinking about the
person walking through the airport they
see this sign
and whereas before it said group
check-in it's like
okay that feels very like way-finder-y
corporate strict how about with a group
head this way and then once you get to
the group check-in area it says
group check-in congratulations let's get
you settled
and it's like yeah if you're traveling
with a group it's probably a pain in the
butt to travel
with a big group like that
uh just another uh example of how it can
come to life
in an environment paired with a little
bit of messaging
uh aspire to travel better and aspire to
better travel
had a little bit of fun with the
interiors playing with that
kind of virgin america a little bit of a
party
treat it like it's fun right you know on
you have thinking about that internal
environment it's
you know those those colors can be uh
soothing it can
it can you know relax you down and sort
of help you
uh just relax in your seat you know and
then of course my brain started going to
things like
what could you do with aromatherapy uh
does united offer little kids that you
can put in your mask and it's uh
you know uh lavender or you know
sandalwood or stuff like that so that
you're smelling something nice and
calming during your flight
going to the uh first aid amenities
you know what are you know obviously on
a lot of things it's okay let's just
put the logo on there keep it simple uh
but again how
can we bring through the different
design elements maybe the pillowcase
takes that same screen printing of the
halftone pattern
and now all of a sudden that becomes a
you know a texture for linens and things
like that
for a sleep mask again let's be playful
and cheeky with our language
what just have it say brb right you'll
be right back you're gonna take a nap
brb
i gotta say a lot of people are
commenting on how you thought this
through from the user experience and
some people are even saying hey i would
book a flight to nowhere
because they want to fly this plane hey
this should accomplish right
well guess what you guys ladies and
gentlemen this is captain chris does
speaking and
we are at a cruising altitude of 30 000
square feet today if you look out to
your left you're going to see maxwell
billings if you look out to the right
you're going to see his design firm
made by 87 i hope you're enjoying
because i this flight and i know
okay you are now headed to nowhere
we're gonna do a lap and come right back
yes um
and then uh you know thinking through uh
you know
if you are going into that that first
class experience what are the little
things that we can leave for you
um you know normally they would just
have a bag that says oh
united airlines again why not just apply
a little messaging on there say welcome
aboard
uh something that has a little bit more
style and panache to it than just
oh hey here's here's more of our logo if
you're on a united
flight you already know that so why
don't we you know treat it as a place to
to message with people wait wait go back
go back go back to the market all right
sorry it's just like it's just like a
leather bag that you're coughing up here
it was yeah yeah okay this is a very
posh airline you guys
very posh look this is for the super
elite
yeah this is like premium first class uh
elite class
i thought there was an opportunity here
maybe it's just me but if it
because it's united welcome aboard what
if it says welcomes
you aboard united welcomes you aboard i
don't know link it right into the
headline
why not well the uh
i mean good opportunity here i was
actually playing around with that but i
ended up stepping away from it but uh
you know it's something as simple as the
coffee cups that you get at
the the premium lounge uh
how do they look again it can be a
little more playful with things and
if you're reaching for a coffee why not
just have it say something like fuel up
uh or if we use chris's direction we can
just take the you logo and drop it into
the up
and call it a day done and done mm-hmm
so that is the presentation
uh just want to say thank you and
uh i can go back to any of the elements
that we want to talk about
answer any questions um had a lot of fun
doing it happy to
happy to have a little q a with you guys
excellent so first of all random
applause everybody
that was nice okay so let's have a
conversation there's a lot of respect
and
love and little ideas here there's a lot
of associations that people are making
so let's address those things
i wasn't able to read all of them i read
a lot of them uh
once again i i can't emphasize this
enough
the presentation was on point the
reasoning taking us through
every little part of the decision making
process the research very well presented
you had me engaged the entire time great
job
and for those of you guys that are
looking at this mark right now
that you're looking at this market like
yeah i could design that i could design
that
the difference between you and somebody
like
maxwell or the big dogs in the space is
the amount of thought attention
that they put into this because the mark
is i know it's difficult to design
but it's not what the companies pay for
they pay for the research the thinking
the analysis the strategic positioning
and they want to make sure
when they give you two four hundred six
hundred thousand dollars for or a
million
to two million dollars for this project
that you've done the due diligence that
you've made sure that you're protecting
them
against having to change the mark in two
months
now i do not love the the hybrid model
logo between united and continental
airlines it looks
old already and a lot of times when
these mergers happen
it's nobody's best logo it's just a
compromise
and eventually they'll roll out another
logo i'm almost 100
certain of that that there's a rollout
plan that we're not privy to as the
public
but sooner or later you'll see one thing
go away and something else becomes more
prominent
like when when all companies merge this
is what happens it's because they don't
want to alienate or lose anybody from
either brand
there's this weird hybrid model so
that's what's happening there just a
little business
inside stuff there so when you're able
to present and think through the problem
as maxwell's done here you start to
elevate yourself
way way way above everybody else in
terms of just
mark makers in terms of people who sell
design services on 99 designs on fiverr
and up work
so when people say like i can't compete
against those people
if you think like you're competing
against them you've already lost
now i'm not judging anybody that's in
that group if you have to make a buck
and that's the only way you know how to
get a client
by all means do that but then you got to
elevate yourself out of that asap and
acquire the skills
that maxwell's displaying for you today
a lot of questions in terms of
how much time did it take you to do
this from start to finish help us
understand because you put a lot of work
into this
yeah um i mean i i will caveat and say
i'm i am kind of notorious for being
quick in photoshop and
just i've been doing this for a long
time so don't let my answer intimidate
you
um but i would say i had been thinking
about this and giving it thought
for probably two and a half three weeks
potentially
and then i would say the last week and a
half has been
uh full-blown in the design field
building the presentation crafting the
story so i mean
you know maybe maybe a month uh total of
just sort of start to finish from
development and everything because as
chris mentioned
you know you're telling a story whenever
you present or build this stuff
so you got to give some thought about
how that unfolds for
folks like you to enjoy it now was this
a very organic process for you that you
got
yourself into the research and the
thinking and then it evolved into this
or did you already kind of have an idea
as to where you wanted to
go and filled in the gaps in between
yeah the i would say 85 percent of it
was
uh just sort of organic learning paying
attention
um i had a an initial thought of where i
kind of wanted things to go
but i didn't let that sort of poison the
well so to speak
of when i started doing my my homework
and researching so
there were a couple things that fell out
that were happy little surprises and
accidents but
i from the start wanted to do something
that was a bit more
uh graphical aspirational felt a little
bit more
you know modern and elevated and also i
think space and that stuff is pretty
cool
so yeah so just to confirm it took you
about a month's worth of work
almost as much time preparing the
presentation as doing the design work
and
believe it or not once you get into the
big leagues that's kind of where a lot
of the time is spent because if you
don't want this to go back to
revision hell you have to do you have to
put together a really thoughtful
deck that tells a story and that makes
all the decisions seem very clear and
logical
that it's not just one designer's
emotional whims and
i woke up this morning this is what i
wanted to look like kind of decision
so are you doing work in the meantime
between this month or did you take a
month off of doing anything and just
work on this
specifically oh god i wish uh yeah no
still doing client work still uh you
know going through the routine and
meeting with people and things like that
so uh yeah i would say the last really
the last
week is when everything truly came
together
of having to block things off and move
things around
um but yeah i mean for
for as much as you can plan and i kind
of learned this from the ad agency world
for as much as you can plan and do all
the upfront work
just know the 48 hours before you
present everything
it's all going to go to [ __ ] and you're
going to have to redo stuff
and that's really when everything starts
to happen
so you could work on it six months out
the
two days before the presentation is
really when things start to pop and the
magic starts to happen
that explains a couple of things because
you kind of been silent with uh sending
us a little bit and then all of a sudden
i wasn't sure what i was going to walk
into
today's call and your your new logo
redesign expert or logo therapist for us
so i had no idea
all i could do is brace for impact so to
speak and hope that you did your best
to present your best and i think you
absolutely did that you did it out of
the ballpark
here's another question coming in and
that you mentioned something about it
feeling
very like space and these colors and and
aspiration on
and we hear a lot about how space travel
is going to be
happening in the next couple of years
and i'm excited for that and so i think
using the they're tying it into their
sub brand
polaris is is that their sub brand
polaris
uh it's uh yeah it's yeah
it it's interesting how they treat it
because it really only comes to life in
those first
first and second class section so it's
really even like consider it a
true sub brand but yes they they do sort
of tip
into that space polaris north star type
of world there
and i love that because see like even in
your
redesign you took into consideration all
the investments they've made
and it's a great jumping off point so
it's like reverse engineering the parent
brand
to make sure it fits together like lego
blocks with a sub brand and i think
that's really smart
and i i loved how you took this star
and turned it into the dot pattern
because there's so many applications of
that and of the three airplane
apps that you showed my favorite was the
first one i loved how organic was i love
the white space
and the the full wrap felt a little
party bus ish to me
but this is very classy it feels
aspirational
it it's just really nice it feels fast
like the colors got pushed into the back
of the plane and seeing
uh what do they call this uh when when
you dip dye shirts um
oh like the ombre
ombre yes ombre man and you're you're on
your point with the language too yes the
ombre kind of fade and i like that and i
like
having the white it feels fresh and
clean and open
and at first i was a little concerned
because the mark itself doesn't
fit in that triangular wedge as well as
it can
because some marks are designed
specifically to fill up that triangle
so they almost designed within that
triangle but you did a great job of
bringing in the
secondary or tertiary elements the
colors the aurora borealis the dot
patterns
this is a really rich identity system
that you've been able to design
some feeling all of that thank you
appreciate it now
one person said that uh in the airline
in the lounging part or not the lounge
i'm sorry
when you're doing the color treatment
the mood lighting i think during that
part they're like i could sleep there
and that's the whole point you don't
want to get on a plane and be distracted
and wired
so that when you land you're jet lagged
and fatigued you you do want it to feel
like the temporary hotel experience
between your next destination and i
think this is exactly the right
vibe and the little accoutrements the
little travel
bonuses that you get in business and
first class i thought you did an
excellent job there
some of you guys who haven't traveled
business class before you every airline
gives you a little something socks
eye masks a toothbrush some of them give
you pajamas to wear
especially if you're flying on one of
the fancier ones it's it's kind of nice
it's nice to be able to like feel that
in in how you thought through everything
and the stitching of the seats excellent
way of bringing in design
we've seen designers in the past take
the logo and deconstruct the logo
and it's repeating the logo in many ways
but i think you found
ways to extend it so it feels fresh and
i'm not getting
logo fatigue so great job there as well
okay the last comment that i saw was oh
it's very millennial
i don't know if that's a good or bad
thing but that sounds good to me
i mean there i i think it's uh if
they're not already there in the next 18
months millennials are going to be the
primary buying force
in in the world so i mean yeah follow
the money
[Applause]
you know what yeah and they're they're
probably the strongest health-wise and
have the strongest
immune system so they're all being on
the plane while all those old people are
at home
worrying about corona yeah
moms and dads aren't you know actively
posting the the travel photos on
instagram that were all
you know smashing the like buttons over
it's you know us millennial travelers
who are
getting out there on cool purple and
green airplanes
okay so there's a technical comment here
uh peter chang is saying unfortunately
you cannot have
multiple colors with in-flight lighting
well maybe at this point in time
maybe they can run two strips of leds
and then they can cycle through them and
have colors blend
we don't know let's not get too
concerned about that i'm sure i can swap
a light bulb
i'm sure yeah something can happen there
you know i got a comment here from uh
edna and she's asking if you have any
specific habits
or systems that help to support your
creative work so i think she's trying to
get into the
the mindset and how you actually perform
the you know the art
crafts sure um i mean
the first thing no matter what is always
think about who that end user is going
to be
who who is going to be sort of on the
receiving end
of what you're creating and then work
backwards from that
thinking about what their needs are
and how they kind of operate and
function and how you can create
something to help
for that that's just a very easy way to
build something into your process to
where you always have something like
pressure test
you can say oh does this really match
with who we're trying to
talk and position to um and then on the
the other element of it is i kind of
treat it
creatively as like rounds so first round
you know come up with as much stuff as
you can nothing's off the table
pick out a bunch of different ideas and
then as you do the process
enough you'll start to figure out like
all right in round two which ones are
working which ones aren't
and then around three whittling it down
even further so that
eventually you can do that all
internally
um and i mean i'm i sort of through my
career have built that muscle
of being able to design directly within
the computer
or you know being able to just creative
direct internally but
really it's just getting into the the
habit of
stepping outside yourself and saying how
does how would somebody else react to
this work
and if you do that that will give you a
fresh new perspective and also improve
the
um the actual effectiveness of what
you're trying to make because
you've looked at it through that lens
all right so before before we take
another question i want to show
everybody here
here's the original logo and the revised
logo
there were some comments and people said
you shouldn't have showed us the the
final logo it's fine
if that bothers you i will never show
you guys the final logo ever again
but here it is i want you guys to go
ahead and drop in your opinion
if you prefer the original or the
revised you can just hit a or b
in the comments and let's see where we
net out and
i won't judge you too harshly depending
on what you vote on but let's see what
happens here
and while we're waiting for that
reaction to happen i want to let
everybody know
if you're interested in maxwell's work
and his firm it's it's called
made by 87 and you guys go made by
87.com to see the rest of his work it's
a pretty impressive body of work
and it's very consistent to what you're
seeing here today he's based out of
chicago illinois and if you want to find
him on instagram it's
made by 87 and it's maxwell billings so
let's see how we did in the voting here
what did they say a or b the votes are
still slow in coming in so let's see
what happens here
sure there we go come on guys there's
like 460 some odd people in this room
is the internet a little slow there's
well there's the delay in the live
stream but yeah i think everyone's going
usually it streams in really fast so
overwhelmingly everybody's saying b
i think it's because you you have a very
strategically and wisely chosen
i think universally hated logo right now
because it's so bad rhonda what are you
doing rhonda
i said i wouldn't judge you but rhonda
there you are look at something okay
yeah you guys can have the original logo
you can keep it for me
i'm going with the revised logo for sure
okay so heavy heavy uh leaning towards
your
revised rebrand and i think that's a
good sign for you
you might have a future in this maxwell
i might be good at this who knows
yeah you know stick it out don't quit
just yet all right yeah we'll see how it
goes
okay now you mentioned something and i
think you said it uh did you go to a
portfolio center
uh i went to portfolio chicago portfolio
school uh portfolio school
yeah here here in chicago that's where i
sort of learned a bit more of the craft
of
advertising how to present how to think
creatively
and then on top of my years of just
being in the design and art world
leading up to that
okay so did you study advertising in
school
yeah study technically marketing
communications
parentheses advertising i know it just
rolls right off the total account
so marcom advertising you got it
uh so graduated in that and then
actually worked as a account person for
a couple years
going into the advertising world which
is client relations and things like that
zero design realized i hated it was not
good at it
and decided to switch to my sort of
passion which is
designing creativity and went to
portfolio school
did that uh you know at evenings intern
during the day
and now fast forward gosh
11 12 years later now we're here
excellent that does explain a lot of
things about you i have to say
you guys don't know this but basically
you're an account person you're dealing
with clients so you have to have a lot
of client human relationship
personal skills you have to be a really
good communicator
and you're dealing with crazy stuff
because most of the times you're caught
between the client
and a hard place which is the other
creatives
and you have to support your client but
you have to sell the creative through
and it's a horrible position to be in
you said you hated it you got out of it
and now you're doing design
and it's great to see that you you've uh
are dipping your toes into animation
and doing really beautiful presentations
i still think your your superpower
personally speaking is the person who's
going to be talking to the client
presenting design to be a champion for
the work that is being done by your firm
and i i love the way that you hold
yourself the way
you communicate i would hire you there
you go
thank you yeah uh knowing how to pitch
is a very valuable skill
[Music]
okay okay mark let's take one more
question and i have to get out of here
so what's what's the last question how
do we end this
um let's see nothing too surprising i
think we've addressed a lot of it a lot
of it was
from the process yeah as i was reading
the comments in real time i was folding
them into the conversation so
there's a lot of love there's a lot of
hand claps for you i believe you can go
and
view the live chat after this so i guess
without further ado
i want to say thank you very much for
joining us and i appreciate the work
that you put into this
and i think if you want to be a local
therapist
you have to be able to kind of put in
this level of work
to help to elevate the game and the
conversation so that we're not
telling people about bad habits i'm
gonna ask everybody for a
huge big favor right now if you've
enjoyed this episode
please share it with somebody that is in
the space a designer who
uses that word branding and say like
check this out this is how you do
branding
and i think that's going to help elevate
the entire field and industry
and the more people that can do that the
more
we can be taken seriously by our clients
so that we're all holding ourselves to
quite a high standard okay now you may
not be at this level today
and nobody is it's taken maxwell a
couple of years to get here
and if we aspire to do this we can learn
and we can grow together
and then and that's it for me and on
behalf of the entire team
jonah and mark maxwell thank you very
much i'm gonna
cut to your slide here and this is how
you guys get in touch with maxwell once
again
he's at madeby87.com go check out his
work clients if you need somebody to do
work for you with you
and you need a partner who can think
things through who understands the
client relationship
this is your person and i also found out
surprisingly
he's also a pro member you guys he's a
pro member so
fam is in the house right now that's it
joanna get the music ready i think i
stalled long enough guys don't forget to
like
comment and subscribe and hit that bell
for notifications
thanks very much for being part of the
one billion mission
1b minus one if you guys want to support
us you know how to send me money i take
cash
credit gifts gold bars anything that's
it for us
see you guys next time i'm out of here
have a great weekend everybody